late Carrie Fisher who was honored with
the star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
yesterday the unveiling fittingly took
place on May the 4th which as you all
know is Star Wars Day her daughter Billy
Lord and Mark Hamill also known as Luke
Skywalker they were there to celebrate
and so were C3PO and R2D2 Fisher who
died in 2016 was of course best known
for her role as the Beloved Princess
Leia her daughter spoke about her Legacy
Leia is more than just a character she's
a feeling she has strength she is Grace
she is a wit she has femininity at its
finest people's love for Leia didn't die
with my mom it continues to get passed
on from generation to generation just
like my mom passed it on to me and I am
now passing it on to my children and
hopefully they will pass it on to theirs